protection
thority right but should we be required
to make great ability would you please
leave your do is find the nearest
available X into the chamber now a
simplified will win the public car park
at the side of the sewage leak please do
not do you like or evacuation routes to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by the council stop
please note that this meeting will be
audio recording the girl be obtained
pleased to receive a check at the Edit
Lee the county fire chief exec in a
debate and attracting talent
good evening everybody and welcome to
our service and our council we think the
first time that is welcome of my
chaplain and ask him to say a few words
please how do you feel cuz i can do the
rest I'm not wearing any comment was a
good evening buddy I just got a story to
tell you and it may be relevant to you
personally or to this council chamber
what a life in general but it's about
purpose and other things like that there
was a little camel it comes from the
mummy cabin and says mum why have I got
such big feet and mummy camel [ __ ] for
going in the desert you need big flat
feet because the sand is soft and then
obviously keep stable oh so the little
campbell goes away as a thickening comes
back against if mum mum whatever got
such big eyelashes well mummy carol says
well in the desert when there's a lot of
wind sand gets strong about in the air
and the big eyelashes not the same
getting in our eyes oh the little camel
stays as a thinking walks away as
another thing comes back and says mommy
mum I haven't got a humpback weld I said
mother cow out in the death sometimes we
without water ice for a long time and we
don't see any water and we got the hump
and it's designed to store a lot of
water and he helps us to survive in
desert ah so the little couple goes away
as a thing and then comes back and says
mum mummy I know we've got big free I
know we've got long eyelashes
and a hum but why we in Bristol Zoo
shall we pray in the name of God
Almighty offer our prayers and thoughts
of this world analysis in particular we
ask the resolution to the continuing
junior doctors dispute in the wake of
the news that 348 power stripes are
being caught called in the face of
impose working contracts by the health
secretary let's set through mail and an
end to an it's late in situations as
extremely serious consequences for the
well-being of animation and if we face
an audience peculation regarding the EU
referendum on the 20 30 jun some of it
informed and some just playing
hysterical give us all wisdom to discern
pluses and minuses and the consequences
of whatever decision will be made so we
can make the best in conscience and best
football and we're also here thanks for
the potential troops in Syria among many
of the main protagonists so the pain and
protection can be admitted when you I
hope might be gross and muscling Prague
renamed to the conflict tonight we think
especially the discussion concerning the
financial strategy in council tax as
final considerations and decisions are
made give our counselors clear minds and
decisive perception to manage and go
into the best of their ability and
service to our community and we write
this pause for a moment to think of
those none to us who might need our
thoughts and our prayers at this time
because they're unwell there is some
kind of pain or hurting mentally or
whatever it may be you just think of
those people now
and now in anticipation racer may the
blessing of God Almighty the loving
father the risen Christ and the truth of
the Holy Spirit be among us now and
always enjoy your much ladies and
gentlemen if you got six
and I happy that April releases I've
seen you I want any help tonight we
report with one hammer to go home
realizing without message and for our
community the first time is probably
doing it apologies for action mr. master
speak German we have publicly small
council Carter canceled Gordon and
councillor Hudson in the office vacant
house would you wanna do anybody else
any other qualities thank you very much
now item 2 is a waste of a meeting 15 of
the 50 that you send up and then it's
only ones on the 12 Mary and the night
at February's are you only braver than
you very much imagine three is
decorations that address they very
humble evacuations tonight thanks very
much I just an item for his announcement
for me I've been very fortunate since
Christmas and before Christmas to go to
so many different places to see people
lots of people small numbers of people
people that are in people that are
disabled and so on and it's been a great
joy and great pleasure to go be with
them for everyone and in many cases
explain things that goes on in ruptured
district I'm not talking just about
rainy I'm talking about going out to
fairness and right across from family to
war of the many things that we have to
offer people in and community and
elsewhere and I hope that it's going to
make a lot of difference in a coming
summer the tourism mean to an area but
the most important thing of the whole of
the time at this point has been the home
of course the presentation it was
amazing there was me another hundred
people came to the mill hall and to the
actual service community or a little
bring peace to have butter village who
once I straight you all night already
and one of the children that came out
from the war started and fever part of
his talk was de Vere with arriving the
habit on the train from and Holland and
in college and he thought my happy
memories because the train that from
height but not only that after he'd
spoken that the girls weren't faithful
and it was very very emotional in
afternoon because the girls have been
and we clever word reports etc etc and
it was amazing how much information came
from that afternoon and I was very hot
bothered at the end afterwards to get a
very nice letter from a little Peter and
also by sheriff and also the bishop a
brothel and name of the three male
guests that came and thanking us for
what we've done and how interesting it
was and how much they've learnt from the
afternoon that the most amazing thing
that I had realized right across the
county there are sounds good as trees
planted unless something around in Essex
but it would appear that our monument
that we have here in rayleigh is quite
unique london IT to think that we took a
long time to get it through and it came
in at every year that [ __ ] admin and it
was chairman and it was the consecrated
then and it's been used essence and i'm
very proud to be here in bailey we have
now left in the past lots of city hope
in the future other things like that and
come up I'm ready we'll be in the
foreground and with that over they'd say
I'm attracted fish provided for there we
go up now
five now I understand because of the
five that should serve and keith gordon
is not present tonight so i just ask
john bostock here the faculty of words
and then do an outside Thank you Thank
You Jeremy in the absence of counsel
Gordon it would be appropriate for a
written answer to be provided to the
question thank you and we will make a
bath leave absolutely play and safe and
we were all get a copy of it before it
goes off and if anybody is not happy
with it then they consult with us a
minimally subject thank you very much
item five this is something else many
things there is no visit in what okay
item seven it's like a divot committee
meeting from the april-december right
through till now are you all the way at
the back thank you item 8a some very big
now that might be happy for an up to
date is in two parts I think I'm
pardon calcium's and I don't probably on
it and did you have a nice journey
across the same and you come back later
better do indeed thank you thank you
very much so big adorable please as a
chair that committee if you prefer
Nicholas tell you well it would prefer
to sit down I would be quite a bit on it
it's entirely up to you um the review
committee looked at the medium term
financial strategy and work generally
happy with it apart from one age Madison
we thinking about how future investment
studies we were told them huge hug Jim
the council's financial position that we
could do is getting something like three
or four times the current level of
investment income than we do at the
moment investments of the Romans are
mainly Louis and we then head over to
see debate because I like myself some
members of the committee of experience
in a world of financial services and
they would be concerned that in order to
make the sort of monies that will be
talked about we might end up having some
iose vestments wonderful time isolation
read my turn they can also in theory
deep losses and some people felt that if
the were losses incurred that would not
be a popular use of council tax pilot
flying
and therefore what we asked the officers
to do was to put together a dummy
portfolio of the sort of investments
they like this to see for the future and
one of three month study on how have you
baseman stupid whether they make money
lose money say the same or whatever and
also ask our financial advisors if they
would do a three month look back at the
last three months for the same portfolio
so we were having theory about six
months data and then we would feel more
comfortable with that data you make
using ground in recommendations to full
council where we had a greater
appreciation of the ratio between with
some more and the offices agreed to do
that and they'll be coming back to our
next meeting to he was at my station
civilian overlooked unit that's why we
that's the only bit of the report that
we thought we knew some cat the Exxon to
thank you very much there's anybody any
questions we have here on tape at the
1.8 and that's on eight points at page
may point soup we have a resolution yes
one country that are you in agreement
with that man of a chef hands give you
up in agreement those agreements make
you anybody a version it has okay and
then we've got 8.1 which is the other
one and this is a report the big
sentencing and countless very would you
still like this with infinity
maybe between members and the offices on
the twenty-third februari where we
discuss two items one is the lots of
district council developments beam 2016
and also the subsequent community
involvement stone I think it's fair to
say that officers and members of
burberry sent view on how these should
be done in future the first subject the
local development scheme is a statutory
requirement where we incorporate our
three main planning documents that will
be subject to your approval here tonight
currently the the last document we have
in place is dated 2005 and to be honest
this is pretty well out of date I think
it's fair to say but we had a fairly
open and robust discussion on on this
and subsequently I'm quite happy to
approve the recommendations that are
made on this item we then moved on
German to item relating to the community
involvement which was even more I have
robust of of them but again I think I
should complement of my mentors and the
offices were joined the front for being
a thousand and transparent as we can be
I think we appreciate it somewhere along
the line we will incur the wrath of
residents but this is just not a
question of building houses this is a
noble view of how we can help the
district in the future and planning
accordingly the only areas that we saw
rather just realistic vultureman was
that on page 8 x 1136 this reference to
arrives health well-being event where
will the bowl that bag is incorrect and
focuses are aware of this and will be
many in the final report and also there
was a reference to a poked event on the
twenty-third of March Afghan offices
will be involved there is no reference
that the guy officers will we include
that in the final report and say I'm
quite happy to recommend approval by
this council excuse me could you give
the page number are you talking about
they undertook results for the section
8.1 recognition so genetically but they
draw a segment of community involvement
include the lonely for the consultation
and I'm sure if I ask public take part
in that better to say what shouldn't
happen if I send them over the spot what
happened to do most budgetarily how when
we consider jaron I think if we pretty
much cut this issue I starcrack your
emphasize that by law as I understand it
we only need to have a six-week
consultation period and we are after the
site trying to be as open and
transparent as we can do this and this
is why we have extended with this
officers recommendation for a nine-week
period this is why we're trying to
engage with difficult to work with
groups that's why we've had a copse and
these other areas to try engage with
these people offices of made it quite
clear they want people to engage they
will then come back to us with with the
recommendations and the phrase with what
has been submitted and then we can go
meet a review of what the recommend
except for Joe for us I'm not together
clear you're saying that officers will
look at the responses and then come back
to members and recommendations might
refer to you Joe but that correct yeah
yeah i mean we're anticipating the
committee is anticipating a
comprehensive report from officers i
don't think there's any doubt that this
is the way that they see this situation
as well chairman but well as many people
involved in this situation if they
possibly can we want to engage with the
public as early as we can and as
comprehensively as we go there is no
ideas of tribe hide anything officers
have made it very clear that there will
be a comprehensive appraisal and report
back to members and we have the
opportunity to discuss whatever is
presented to us one final thank you you
assure me that pacific imagine afsar
didn't come back to the full counts
Jeremy not initially it will come back
to the ovf committee and obviously
there's a junction with officers we will
make our recommendations but I cannot
really emphasize there is no intention I
can assure you and tickling some of the
members that are involved in this
committee not to be as open and
transparent and to engage as early as we
can and as comprehensively as we can
with our residents thank you very much
with everybody else no man can I say on
81 121 it results in 1.4 are you will
agree by the show of hands please thank
you very much education thank you very
much and then over the age of eight
13 it's 28 is now resolved there the
first one and I'll do it two colors the
first one number one on your wasn't very
much of that thank you very much and
then the second one again I'll show of
hands yeah that's a channel with the
amendments that we've mentioned about
the dates I think you'd expected thank
you very much thank you very much my
state order pickers are done with thank
you very much and we have an item nine
of those certain musicians we have one
here as my point one and is a report
it's just a nose are you all happy with
that face look at you thank you very
much CBP now we go on Shah Mardan it
seems we have a lot and panting no it's
not big
this is a written policy okay thank you
okay anybody else wanna talk the other
oh you don't sleep thank you very much
on equal hair from the leader of the
capsules and now this to one is eyes and
came first how to cut one hi I'm just as
everybody knows hop in thank you very
much need to be less nexgen have a
chance right the support leader of the
work of the executive this is the pit
bull Murray Council 19 4 215 16 units
per year I would like to work on the
members since the council council
meeting lot of good things to December
there have been no further executive
meetings other matters of my colleagues
in Iowa executive a condemning with
include referring to our that grant
funding a 35,000 for various local
organizations the greening of the
council signs up to the Memorandum of
Understanding alot more enforcement
activity prepared by essex county
council a green of a formal response to
chocolate city council presentation or a
new local plans issues and options
document within the statutory time
period 19 details in december for
protection and effective exceptions
report apple will help you have a sec
many questions remembers irrespective of
the
detective I'm sure my fifties will be
happy two countries over sunday i will
in agreement i love this woman first man
when they now go to fashion show
nowadays we have helped to cut and what
they can bill for voluntary activity
report the leader on setting the council
tax chairman of three year councillors
nin to the public and press this is my
12 budget need within certain
administration the budget pressures
under which local government operates
and intensified and this authority is
increasingly looking at how we can
generate savings and increase revenue
this is not only in response to cuts
you'll never the throng and send us our
but also to significant costs and
different pressures there's been a
significant reduction in the level of
financial group provided by the
government this is a fifty percent
reduction for 2016-17 rather than
reducing 20 x 17 18 by doing so the
government has little opposition Council
the opportunity to take control of its
firing position and it becomes self
sustained and come job sustaining by
2021 cutting the fires of ripping the
support rod nor some of these to use in
terms of location hunting continuing
with vital services this means that
along it significant demographic growth
and inflation pressures there will be a
funding gap of the relative my head
minion rush 20 21 which must be an extra
savings plans revenue growth and
potential funding options looking to the
Future Oxford district councillors now
prove the new business plan setting out
of high-level priorities of
to work towards in the next four years
it seems to the renewed focus on captive
essence and the plan of future liberal
delivery documents will provide a clear
direction and important get the use of
council resources to deliver priorities
priorities are to become financially
self-sufficient to use early
intervention to manage demand upon our
services to maximize our exit actually
language communities despite the
challenges faced we have continued to
deliver excellent services through our
rhythms our achievements over the past
year include the seventh Rock Philip
trail which player posted dozens of
artists who exhibited their talents in
the town shops cafes and businesses
excellent progress by our platform which
was set up to help tackle and reduce the
flood risks to the district's grow very
improvements engine the 12th annual
world would say which took place on the
thirtieth of a 15 that pop see woods and
was our most successful to date
attracting over four thousand visitors
the sourcing of 50,000 pounds worth of
funding which was distributed to local
businesses to support them and help them
grow holding to the First Parish town
council summits that's part of our
commitment to work together in the
interests of residence continuing to
provide local businesses with advice and
support including hosting various
business and skills society events
delivering a further range of some of
all of these sports and arts activities
in partnership with Fusion lifestyle
born in bronze floating 35,000 pounds to
a range of community initiatives around
the district lettuce or traded when
you're being awarded wedding venue of
the year something different envy essex
wedding blooms as part of an illness
ability another pase as part of an
innovative sports development apprentice
program help the train apprentices to
work alongside sports government offices
during crystal and physical activity
services growing fruit and nvq level
three
next books develop further celebrating
and honoring local sporting talent rocks
with Castle Point sports award sponsored
by future life so following the first
Halloween to it that I hope the op house
is proved very popular a family theater
program of shows set in place at the
middle of an event center near 80 run by
water district council in pop ship again
with of the future lifestyle about
charity pins project much game you
selected as a finalist association for
public service excellence awards over
31,000 pounds being recovered as a
result successful benefit for
prosecution's being awarded the national
land and property visited is pretty
prestigious award for maintaining the
district's address details to the high
standard each month the last year after
the fifth year probably need young
interpreters event in partnership with
enterprise in education achieving a
recycling rate excess of sixty-five
percent over the year that's quite
wonderful gym in September 2015 the
results were which passions are served
it at London salad airport the uk's best
airport for the third consecutive year
following the council's electoral
boundaries you during 2015 biometry
approval was given to reduce the number
Northern District from nineteen is the
13 there will be three councillors for
each Ward this will come into force at
the local elections to be held in may
2016 because the fifth dimension as a
responsible council we will continue to
look at areas where costs can be reduced
early I've generated wherever 8 16 17
there isn't the internet week's Capitol
textbook 1.93 sent here from the huge
financial strain the district is
currently facing and cut the tires and
on central government funding this
equates to an increase of setting for it
certainly put their soul for week the
proposal in this report wish to set
right for district council tax repair
indeed property at 213
two pence per year the breakdown tomato
council tax rebounding property will be
xxxx County Council worked out in 130
pounds 13 pics police and crime
commissioners 406 152 pounds techniques
essex far a rescue or 30 60 768 pence
the average town or parish council 41
pounds of seven unseen rockford district
council 250,000 to tax the total average
council tax for abandoned property for
2016 17 or 16 17 will be 1600 pounds an
increase of 50 4069 that's proximately
through half percent in conclusion will
over four districts and egrets the UK
they still suffering from the effects of
the economic downturn the count remains
committed to providing excellent
services to its residents and part with
it in mind the caps will be doing
already care to deliver innovative and
high-quality services general i
commended watch it's tricking out your
tax from your approval thank you have
more pleasant one last question and
that's how I think that's somewhere
lousy council a paragraph this everyone
we see the last 40 years look you up in
paragraph because you will have a look
special to the line person reading it
learn the party but it's you have the
face about budget pressures intensifying
and looking for
it was ever person but he's getting
worse and we never lost it will work
like before I've got to say when
counselor couple says by doing so the
government has given the box initiative
council the opportunity to take control
with finance an issue but is being a
little bit too neat ethic bring your
group I think should kick em all the
fuss and tell them and subby you're not
sugar you steady when we get the best
for residents nwt pathetic up to you not
to the hospital and that's not fair
you're taking a bullet that we local you
should be doing that I'm going to say I
think we have a very inventing a good
officer to run it's no good the
effectiveness to be included poems in or
people hope you are difficult financial
time I commend the alien to try and
people were desperate as well as if you
can use of our services we will not even
get tougher and it's not that the exit
derivative but I will be supporting the
sir like an emotion in terms of looking
my savings will now to look at other
companies and see whether the which
other demolish the Republican versus on
to follow very much indeed next person
is canceled mr. Mason thank you sure
sounds like the voice is going to go
again beneath I think we limited the
position we found ourselves in had
extraordinary for counsel when we looked
at our medium-term financials
with ideas and we recognize what a very
poor deal you have I don't see that we
need to keep on saying that I just think
it needs to be set in a different place
and the different place must be via NP
to the cabinet any particular George
awful but of course that's not something
words tends to happen in politics I want
to ask the question the question relates
to something that I probably not notice
or certainly hadn't been brought to my
attention in previous years I know that
the government has decided by law we
have to have a recorded vote for
approving council tax I've got no
problem with that follow we stand up to
be counted one way or another but in the
recommendations which runs from 4.1 it
seems that we are proving the council
tax resident council now we seem to be
proving the presets from other
organizations and it just puts a little
bit of a problem for me because I'm not
proving the overt although we don't set
them so the way the recommendation is
written get seeds suggest that that's
what we're doing I'd like to us to find
a way in good sense to ensure that we
don't approve other organizations
council tax and precepts so i'll leave
that the new trims obviously for the
office institute come back and see how
we can solve it thank you very much over
the last chance make up an IV is to
reply now Roger want to wait till never
personally lot of processes doing it in
an MIT account services why you a name
and I am I want fearfully increase on
the basis that has crystallized dating
me and I can't all get an act making
government could fatally the socially
built-in home so on that basis I want
this port in subject and kept me very
much in any appeals of the question
announcer how can I I think Polly
Brighton a young man Thank You truth and
she's got to ask a question number she
has a couple as to what representation
he made or any other members of me
getting major agency central government
and what sort of responses you got very
mind the dramatic changes in their the
financing for support thank you very
much it's a anybody else for their
questions thank you my mouse cancer cut
more negative the council take a reply
to all with you should i plant ask the
questions as best I can with in the
words of the the what I saved the point
about the freedom is that usually the
money comes from somebody else they have
a if you like he who pays the piper they
were telling you how you should spend it
now of course if they're not giving us a
money the in that difficult freedoms to
decide how we stink and that's how
that's phrase so we take charge of our
budget chairman and that's what was
including document really my spatially
apartment okay a chairman a lot of the
representation for Essex was done
through capsular Fitch pinched the
leader Essex County Council who always
in touch with throughout the process he
actually went out to see Greg Clark many
other offices on several occasions has
have the officers of Essex County
Council who represented I think the
Essex authorities extremely well mean as
much as as you may know we actually got
some money back from government from the
original budget that came forward after
their representations so in that way I
think I'll answer the last question as
well as the sec
Jim as far as the if you like approving
other chaos with fuzzy so I think that
semantics Jim what we're saying if
you're approving it to go on because
we're the ones who said the bill tail so
we're approving it if you like to
actually going f it was at those things
it doesn't even say the in Syria grid
with other organizations I think that's
just semantics chin and as far as the
question the pork pressure was concerned
we're not approving an increase each
other when we're done that you've done
it object that was done at the last
meeting and it's been approved and lips
have been approved so I'm afraid the
cancerous have to be wrong better than
that thank you very much thank you very
much for that now because of all the
sands this must be a recorded vote so I
will our Soviet to standard silver just
just a confirm that there is a legal
requirements for recording ones as
addictive as the district is a building
authority and it's in that context in
the living Authority the votes should be
taken on block size it's it's all them
on paper by recorded vote thank you
thank you briefly I council that mr.
Saunders professional are more people
consequences if you [ __ ] today I'm
expecting emotion I don't know I'm going
out for a minute council got my mother
come by just to say to know their voting
district verification we're voting on
all of the resolutions is that correct
on block just made it very clear to
everyone yes sherry thank you go it's
done rock hold on
don't hear so and so he will you please
laughing children who is a legal
requirement for the district to act as
building authorities there is a timeline
to that and tinnitus is well set to
achieve the paperwork and etcetera that
comes from that Jen Thank You counselor
black cancels butcher cancel cuddle cool
kelso dry for cancer Gibson counselor
mrs. Glenn or counselor Griffin or
culture mrs. Hale counselor Hazelwood
counselor hook brain cancer mrs. Foy
okay cancer mr. Hoyle
cancer yawning or plan sir norman or
counselor Maddox or counselor mrs. Mason
or cancel mr. Mason yes 4 cancels
McPherson cancel Merrick or cancel Rotom
our counselor mrs. pavlin councils is
wrong cancel sigas for cancer Smith or
Chancellor softly kalsa mrs. Spencer or
counselor sparing or counselor scepter
or cancel award for counselor web or
counselor mrs. Weston cancel mrs. well
please
cancel a hater so I canceled a hater and
when I was get a matter saying it seems
so how you get from any of you so we're
very quiet somewhere even worse and
somebody should leave an alpha lick it
at the end this is the results that's
looking at that missile come some
picture motion is carried 28 for one
against three seconds thank you thank
you very much indeed an app that its own
Rick announcer money okay quickly
yes I summer night cream review my boss
please use your apple time capsule
relative resistance and it is our annual
pay policy statement that we have to
make under the everybody have the
counselor point mr. boring one thank you
honey care as easy language to be
picking numbers as a tax accountant I
just like it's we learn proper night
tonight accepting 27
the table 7 hi sorry yes we've done it
I'm being held at my side nicely done it
before pre machine is it sort of been
corrected I think you must come to
report report other so kept up your
advice I have something called illegal
tax avoidance there's no such thing you
have tax avoidance you color feet legal
activation is illegal nothing we bring
locked it up and some gap terminology
correct yeah it's a bit late here I
think it's not hard to get away thank
you thank you muchly countersink it runs
a trusting person Bible Porter the
viewer now it's focused at the council
was rather and frankly it was something
we should clouded the issue who's he
introduced by some chap rolling brownout
I believe when he was a samsung big
league in second government and it's
totally wrong to actually use that
description because there are many forms
of highly legal avoidance of tax we make
them every day when we choose whether or
not to purchase items for instance and
that isn't the very simplest form of it
in avoiding paying the AC or something
or import duties all sorts of things are
legal avoidance of text and I think this
should be created for future reference
we do not have fall in line with the
definition provided by former childhood
yo Braille and may I say it multiple of
this that this is something that would
be noted so when next year you are
sending thing to change this washroom oh
it might take another my basic it will
be changed also a very fragile minds are
you all in agreement with but a 13 yo
hands please thank you very much and
with that let's finish when my use of
gentlemen I didn't Creek ship that would
be so quickly over I hope you will have
to know how / your watch on your lapel
mic you have a good weekend
I
you